- La mort du pompier Pierre
Lacroix, alors qu'il tentait
de secourir des plaisanciers
dans les rapides de Lachine,
vaut aujourd'hui à la Ville
de Montréal une contravention.
MARIE-CLAUDE NORMANDIN, CNESST
- Pour ce type d'infraction-là,
en fait, le montant c'est écrit
au communiqué de presse,
le montant de l'amende
peut varier entre 17 680 $
et 70 727 $.
- C'est que le Service de
sécurité incendie de Montréal,
le SIM, qui relève de la Ville,
est montré du doigt par
la CNESST pour plusieurs lacunes
dans sa gestion du secteur
nautique. La formation
déficiente des pompiers
est sévèrement c
- Ce sont des gens qui occupent
le PC mais qui n'ont pas
forcément les compétences
au niveau du sauvetage nautique.
Donc, évidemment, ils ne peuvent
pas prendre des décisions.
- La CNESST note aussi
de sériemes avec
les HammerHead, les bateaux
utilisés par le SIM.
DANNY LAPOINTE,
inspecteur, CNESST
- Le bateau est un peu l'arbre
qui cache le reste de la forêt,
dans le sens que, effectivement,
il a ses limitations. Ce bateau-
là a des... défis, si on veut.
Il a des limitations. Mais
c'est pas le seul élément,
parce que, à ce moment-là,
un des éléments les plus
importants, c'est que
ces pompiers-là n'auraient
jamais dû se retrouver aussi
loin, aussi profondément dans
la zone d'interdiction du SIM.
- L'équipage, confirme
la CNESST, a franchi la zone
d'exclusion, là où les pompiers
ont reçu l'ordre du SIM
de ne plus intervenir à la suite
d'un chavirement en 2010.
ÉRIC DUPONT, inspecteur, CNESST
- La zone interdite était censée
se retrouver dans les GPS.
Elle ne s'y retrouvait plus.
C'est important de tracer
des zones. C'est importantmportt
de les mettre dans le système
de GPS. Mais il faut que
les travailleurs puissent
se retrouver, hein,
parce que sur l'eau, sans GPS,
de venir identifier une ligne,
c'est impossible.
- La Ville et le syndicat
des pompiers prennent acte
de ce rapport, mais demeurent
prudents.
CHRIS ROSS, président, Ass. des
pompiers de Montréal
- Ils n'ont pris aucun moyen
contraignant de forcer
l'employeur de les
ALAIN VAILLANCOURT, conseiller,
arr. du Sud-Ouest, Ville de Mtl
- Maintenant, il est trop tôt
pour porter des conclusion,
mais nou fond
de cette affaire.
- La Ville de Montréal
a 30 jours pour décider si elle
contestera cette contravention.
suite des choses,
elle préfère attendre
les conclusions de l'enquête
publique que la coroner
débutera au mois de novembre. I,
Radio-Canada, Mon